[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in ein erfolg besteht nicht
darin dass niemals fehler gemacht werden
sondern dass der gleiche fehler nicht
zweimal passiert hat george bernard shaw
gesagt der satz steht in jedem
management lehrbuch und er passt gut zu
diesem tag an dem die
sachverständigenkommission des bundes
rückblickend die deutschen corona
maßnahmen bewertet die beteiligten
expertinnen und experten üben deutliche
kritik an der wirksamkeit mancher
regelungen und am robert koch institut
aber wir haben es beim thema corona ja
beinahe schon geahnt sie kommen zu
keinem durchgehend eindeutigen ergebnis
und sie sehen sich auch selbst in der
kritik welche folgen das jetzt konkret
haben muss dazu spreche ich gleich mit
dem gesundheitsminister erst britta
spiekermann und die details aus dem
heutigen bericht
der sachverständigenausschuss heute
nachmittag beim
bundesgesundheitsminister mit einer
dringenden leseempfehlung was überaus
freundlich überreicht wird hat durchaus
brisanz wir hoffen also dass sie freude
beim lesen haben dass ihn der bericht
auch unterstützung liefert in ihrem
sicherlich leichen amt und ich darf
ihnen den berichten über gehen viel zu
lächeln gibt es allerdings nicht
lauterbach wäre nicht lauterbach wenn er
das gutachten zumindest in auszügen
nicht schon längst gelesen hätte in der
nacht zuvor lektüre einer sehr
kritischen bilanz nach fast zweieinhalb
jahren pandemie das bringt eine
zusätzliche wichtige perspektive es wird
nicht die alleinige perspektive sagen
mit der bdp in den nächsten monaten
managen es wird aber auch einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten waren die
politischen maßnahmen
verhältnismäßig waren sie überhaupt
wirksam welchen schaden haben sie
verursacht das sind zentrale fragen des
gutachtens stichwort lockdown je länger
ein lockdown dauert und je weniger
menschen bereit sind die massnahmen
mitzutragen das haben einige studien
gezeigt desto geringer ist der effekt
und umso mehr schwerer werden eben auch
die unerwünschten wirkungen unerwünschte
wirkungen etwa auf die psyche von
kindern und jugendlichen und auf die
situation von familien die viel stärker
ins blickfeld gerückt werden müssten ob
schulschließungen bei der pandemie
bekämpfung wirksam waren sei weiterhin
offen für den herbst schließen die
gutachterinnen und gutachter nichts aus
wenn alle stricke reißen dann muss man
gegebenenfalls auch zu schließungen noch
mal ins auge fassen was wir hier sehr
deutlich schreiben ist dass das das
letzte aller mittel ist und dass wir uns
auch jetzt darauf vorbereiten müssen
dass wenn schulschließungen dass sie
alle wirklich alle digitalen endgeräte
haben was immer noch nicht gewährleistet
sei im dritten jahr der pandemie
hauptkritik des ausschusses der mangel
an daten an studien die
wissenschaftliche überprüfung der korona
maßnahmen sei deswegen lückenhaft und
vorläufig
man muss sagen dass die erfüllung dieses
auftrags dadurch erheblich erschwert
wurde dass wir eben zu bewerten erst
zwei jahre nach beginn der maßnahmen
aufgefordert worden sind und dass es
ferner auch nicht gelang seit dem beginn
der pandemie eine ausreichende
stringente und begleitende datenerhebung
zu etablieren und mit diesen
einschränkungen muss die kommission aber
auch die gesellschaft umgehen keine
stringente datenerhebung das zuständige
robert koch institut im kritischen fokus
der rücktritt von lkw chef wähler seien
unausweichlich sagt in die fdp.die
liberalen ohnehin über kreuz mit der
vergangenen corona politik sehen sich
durch das gutachten bestärkt wir können
nach dem was wir heute wissen sicher
sagen dass eingriffe wie locker und die
schulschließung und ausgangssperren
nicht mehr verhältnismäßig sind mit
diesen instrumenten wollen wir nicht
mehr arbeiten das gutachtergremium stand
von anfang an unter keinem guten stern
zu wenig daten zu wenig personal am ende
des tages ist die botschaft jedoch klar
aus der vergangenheit lernen staatliche
maßnahmen seien mitunter notwendig der
gesellschaftliche schaden müsse
allerdings immer überprüft werden
der bundesgesundheitsminister ist bei
uns karl lauterbach guten abend grünen
abend esse was aus fehlern sollte man
lernen das gilt immer im leben was
lernen sie dann aus dem bericht jetzt
für die pandemie politik der zukunft ja
ich weiß nicht ob man von fehlern hier
reden kann aber es gibt anregungen
offenbar war es so dass am beginn der
pandemie die datenlage nicht gut genug
gewesen ist das verändern gerade durch
den panamera den wir jetzt aufbauen wo
wir schneller die daten dann bekommen
werden aus dem krankenhaus und wie viele
leute sind infiziert wäre es auf der
intensivstation wie viele freie betten
haben wir noch also das sind alles dinge
die jetzt verändert werden ob die hätten
wir auch verändert ohne dass gutachten
weil wir diese probleme ja kanten gut
dann gehen wir mal eins nach dem anderen
durch sie sagen die datenlage am beginn
sei nicht gut gewesen die
wissenschaftler bemängeln die datenlage
die gesamte zeit kommt gleich ich möchte
erstmal mit einer maßnahme beginnen bei
den wissenschaftler jetzt im
sachverständigenausschuss sagen nur am
anfang wirksam der lockdown zweig drei
regeln immer nur am anfang wirksam
danach lässt die wirkung sehr stark nach
müssen diese maßnahmen jetzt für die
zukunft komplett vom tisch sein wir
machen ja jetzt gerade einen neuen
maßnahmenkatalog die verhandlungen von
marco buschmann dem justizminister und
wir haben heute schon begonnen da will
ich nicht vorweg greifen worauf wir uns
einigen klar ist dass lockdown masse
also regeln weltweit wenig gebracht
haben nach dem beginn der pandemie somit
glaube ich nicht dass das jemals nochmal
vorsehen werden also sind ja jetzt auch
ganz andere verhältnisse aber viele
andere maßnahmen die im bericht genannt
werden sind wirksam gewesen da ist ja
nur die regel die dass sie am anfang
wirksamer sind als am ende aber
tatsächlich wenn jetzt schon wieder
stark steigende fallzahlen zu beobachten
sind dann kann es sein dass die eine
oder andere maßnahme wieder sinnvoll ist
es gibt noch immer keinen nachfolger für
das infektionsschutzgesetz das ende
september bereits ausläuft die fdp sie
haben sie ja gerade schon kurz erwähnt
wollte erst noch dieses gutachten
abwarten was konkret bekommen sie denn
mit der fdp gemeinsam jetzt hin an
maßnahmen ja wir haben heute tatsächlich
also marco buschmann und ich werden
heute tatsächlich ein anderthalb stunden
sehr intensiv verhandelt wir haben uns
einfach vorgenommen dass wir vertraulich
fanden dass wir nicht öffentlich und
sagen was wir vorhaben was wir nicht
machen dass wir keine also roten linien
ziehen und dergleichen ich glaube wir
werden schnell sein die fdp hat sich ja
gewünscht dass wir es beginnen wenn
dieses gutachten vorliegt für mich wäre
es vorher auch schon möglich gewesen
aber das ist egal lange rede kurzer sinn
wir sind jetzt in die arbeit eigentlich
die genannten stunden heute gute arbeit
wir werden in den nächsten wochen dann
gutes so infektionsschutzgesetz
vorberaten und das brauchen die bürger
auch die bürger erwarten zu recht dass
wir im herbst gut vorbereitet sind denn
wir sind vor schweren wellen im herbst
und im winter ja und der herbst ist ja
schon bald sie sprechen die menschen
gerade an wie wollen sie denn
verständnis erwarten bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern in deutschland für maßnahmen
die jetzt von den experten als nicht
oder kaum wirksam bezeichnet worden sind
ja es sind ja eigentlich ganz wenige
maßnahmen hier als kaum wirksam
beschrieben worden zum beispiel der
früher lockdown
das ist klar das würden wir nicht
wiederholen aber sonst ist der also
maßnahmenkatalog der ist breit wir
brauchen da das wir wissen wirklich auch
ja alle marken hat lauterbach masken nur
bei korrekten sitz ffp zwei masken die
wirksamkeit fragezeichen
schulschließungen gab es keine klare
meinung bei den experten heute die einen
sagen hilft nicht die anderen sagen es
hilft die kultusministerkonferenz sagt
eine sache können wir garantiert
feststellen dass nämlich das
bildungsniveau gerade der viertklässler
erheblich gelitten hat das ist richtig
also sie sprechen ja eine schwäche des
gutachtens an im gutachten sind also
viele maßnahmen bewertet worden nach dem
motto sie helfen aber wir wissen nicht
wie stark sie heißen zum beispiel bei
hier bei den masken das ist natürlich
klar wie auch dort beschrieben wenn die
maske nicht perfekt sitzen dann wirken
sie nicht so gut aber darum kann man
nicht sagen dass masken die nicht
perfekt sitzen gar nicht wirken somit
also da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein
ich fand das gutachten spannend aber auf
der anderen seite ist es auch nur ein
baustein die internationale literatur
ist da unser expertenrates ta wir werden
also hier ein
reichhaltiges also füllhorn von
wissenschaftlicher literatur haben
woraus wir uns bedienen um die maßnahmen
zu begründen dann sprechen wir über die
datenbasis für all das die
wissenschaftler man kann vielleicht
sagen die datenbasis ist eine
katastrophe das wussten wir ja bereits
jetzt haben wir es schwarz auf weiß auch
in dem gutachten ich zitiere mal
zentrales problem war dass es nicht
gelang seit beginn der pandemie eine
ausreichende begleitende datenerhebung
zu etablieren die fdp fordert jetzt dass
sie den lkw chef als verantwortlichen
für diese misere entlassen tun sie das
das wird nicht stattfinden lothar wieler
hat mein volles vertrauen und so
schlecht war die datenlage ja auch gar
nicht also wir haben über die instanzen
immer relativ also gut bescheid gewusst
und dann darf auch nicht alles zerreden
deutschland ist besser durch die panne
gekommen als viele orte hat man damit
vergleich das als
sachverständigengremium wirft ihnen
heute vor dass es eine datenerhebung
eine stringente ausreichende und
begleitende nicht gegeben hat was ist
nicht gegeben hat ist beispielsweise
eine schnelle berichterstattung aus den
kliniken wie viele leute sind jetzt mit
kofi den behandlungen wie viele betten
haben wir noch das führe ich jetzt ein
das wird im september spätestens oktober
zur verfügung stehen tagesgenau wir
machen das abwasser monitoren das haben
wir heute im kabinett beschlossen dass
wir das machen wir machen an der
erhebung in den kliniken wo wir mit
kuwait oder durch kurven unterscheiden
das wissen der stirbt eigentlich durch
kurven oder wir kommen einfach mit kurve
den die klinik somit all diese dinge
werden dies aufgegriffen hier sind ja
zum teil an also kritikpunkte
vorgetragen worden die den anfang der
pandemie besprechen was nützt dieser
blick nach hinten ich blicke nach vorn
der pandemie radar mit diesen daten der
wird uns im herbst gute dienste tun sagt
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister ich danke für
das gespräch ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch aber aus termingründen am
nachmittag aufgezeichnet
nächstes thema heute abend dass die
gaspreise dramatisch nach oben gegangen
sind das dürften alle mitbekommen haben
und wirklich spüren werden dass die
haushalte jetzt wohl schneller als
gedacht und zwar auch alle dem zdf und
der nachrichtenagentur reuters liegt ein
entwurf der bundesregierung vor der
offenbar schon in einer woche im energie
sicherungs gesetz verankert werden soll
danach soll es eine neue umlage geben
das heißt mehr kosten würden auf
praktisch alle kunden verteilt der
hintergrund ist dass die ersten gas
importeure in wirtschaftliche
schwierigkeiten geraten
elisabeth schmidt hat mehr dazu
alles beginnt hier das gas des kreml
herrschers kommt immer spärlicher es
soll europa spalten sagt die
bundesregierung über diese rohre fließt
das gas aus russland gas das deutsche
energieversorger monatelang im voraus
bestellt haben doch weniger als die
hälfte kommt momentan überhaupt noch an
die reduktion der gaslieferungen durch
social 1 ist eben auch ein angriff auf
uns ein ökonomischer angriff auf uns
deutschlands größter gasimporteur
juniper hat den start bereits um hilfe
gebeten das muss jetzt andernorts teuer
eingekauft werden die mehrkosten will
die bundesregierung jetzt gleichmäßig
auf die gas kunden verteilen in einem
entwurf zur anpassung des energie
sicherheitsgesetze es zwei entscheidende
punkte die bundesregierung kann in
dieser sache ohne zustimmung des
bundesrats entscheiden und anstelle des
sogenannten preisanpassung rechts tritt
ein durch umlagefinanzierte ausgleich
für die energieversorger jetzt geht es
darum hat sich die systemrelevanten
unternehmen auch sich und zu sichern
damit wir alle auch weiter überhaupt
eine gasversorgung haben und dafür dient
diese umlageverfahren die schlechte
nachricht ist natürlich es wird uns alle
treffen es wird teuer werden höhere heiz
und stromkosten ursprünglich war geplant
dass die energieversorger bei einem
akuten gas mangel ihre mehrkosten direkt
an die kunden weitergeben dürfen die
höhe hätten die versorger selbst
festgelegt jetzt soll es eine
einheitliche regelung für alle
energieanbieter geben das lehnen wir ab
das ist flickschusterei und wir brauchen
eigentlich andere ansätze zum beispiel
dass auch die energieanbieter auch die
börsenhändler dass die auch beteiligt
werden an den preisen es kann nicht sein
dass die endverbraucher das zu 100
prozent zahlen der rät russland den
gashahn nach dem 11 juli komplett zu
dann wird die pipeline nord stream 1
gewartet unwägbare zeiten die
wirtschaftsminister der länder schwören
die gesamte gesellschaft bei ihrem
treffen heute schon mal auf verzichten
jede kilowattstunde zählt deswegen sind
auch einsparmaßnahmen sowohl in der
wirtschaft aber auch bei bürgerinnen und
bürgern unser appell aus dieser
wirtschaftsministerkonferenz nächste
woche schon könnte die gasanlage
beschlossen werden die folgen des kreml
krieges eine zerreißprobe für die
gesellschaft in deutschland
ja und vor dem hintergrund dass es große
geldsorgen gibt und große unsicherheit
passierte heute der neue bundeshaushalt
das kabinett habe ganz genau und der
sieht erstmals seit drei jahren wieder
vor dass die im grundgesetz verankerte
schuldenbremse eingehalten wird die
neuverschuldung in diesem jahr noch 100
38,9 milliarden euro beträgt soll sie
2023 nur noch bei 17,2 milliarden liegen
bundeswirtschaftsminister lindner will
dafür auch auf rücklagen zurückgreifen
die union kritisierte den plan als
kartenhaus auch mit blick auf die
wirtschaftlichen unwägbarkeiten
ende november muss noch der bundestag
über den haushalt abstimmen
die ukraine hat der russischen armee
vorgeworfen die schlangen insel im
schwarzen meer am abend mit
phosphorbomben angegriffen zu haben das
schrieb der ukrainische armeechef auf
telegramm russland hat bisher noch nicht
auf die anschuldigungen reagiert erst
gestern hatte moskau seine truppen von
der strategisch wichtigen insel
abgezogen und auch an land gingen die
kämpfe weiter nach odessa wurden laut
ukraine 21 menschen durch einen
russischen raketenangriff getötet
darunter auch kinder getroffen wurde
unter anderem ein mehrfamilienhaus 39
menschen sollen verletzt worden sein
das ukrainische außenministerium hat
sich von einer aussage des ukrainischen
botschafters in deutschland melnik
distanziert melnik hatte in einem
interview den früheren ukrainischen
nationalisten führer stepan bandera
verteidigt und gesagt wanderer sei kein
massenmörder von juden und polen gewesen
die polnische regierung bezeichnete die
äußerungen als absolut inakzeptabel
wanderer wird von einem teil der ukraine
als freiheitskämpfer am zweiten
weltkrieg gefeiert für historiker gilt
er als antisemit er wird für verbrechen
an zehntausenden juden und polen mit
verantwortlich gemacht
die türkei hat den internetauftritt der
deutschen welle gesperrt begründet wird
der schritt damit dass der
auslandssender nicht die erforderliche
zulassung habe die deutsche welle hatte
eine geforderte lizenz nach eigenen
angaben bewusst nicht beantragt weil
dies die zensur von redaktionellen
inhalten durch die türkische regierung
ermöglicht hätte kritiker bezeichnen den
schritt an karas als politisch motiviert
und sorgen sich um die pressefreiheit in
der türkei auch der us auslandssender
voice of america ist betroffen
seit heute übernimmt tschechien für ein
halbes jahr den eu-ratsvorsitz
ministerpräsident jahja empfing dazu
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen in
der unesco welterbe stätte schloss
lottomittel östlich von prag
schwerpunkt der ratspräsidentschaft sind
die russische aggression gegen die
ukraine die energiekrise und ein
gipfeltreffen der 27 staats und
regierungschefs in prag
es gab schon vor 25 jahren die die
gewarnt haben und große sorgen hatten da
war hong kong noch die freieste
wirtschaftsmetropole der welt darüber
gaben die briten ihre damalige
kronkolonie an die machthaber in peking
und die versprachen den menschen in
hongkong damals sie müssten sich nicht
der kommunistischen partei unterwerfen
ein land zwei systeme
heute ist die stimmung düster hongkong
leidet unter der drakonischen corona
politik chinas ist dabei seinen status
als internationales finanzzentrum zu
verlieren und wer die regierenden
kritisiert muss mit schlimmen folgen
rechnen 25 jahre später ist aus dem
liberalen quirligen hongkong ein
polizeistaat geworden miriam stein mit
mehr
casey bonn kennt die macht der bilder in
hongkong ist er für seine kunstaktion
bekannt schon vor drei jahren hat er den
verlust der freiheit betrauert
für mich bedeutet der erste juli nicht
dass hongkong zum chinesischen
mutterland zurückkehrt für mich ist es
der tag an dem die kommunistische partei
einmarschiert ist und hongkong
annektiert hat für mich gibt es da
nichts zu feiern
für den chinesischen präsidenten gibt es
was zu feiern
es ist sein triumph hongkong soll eine
normale chinesische stadt sein unter dem
kommando der kommunistischen partei die
den ping inszeniert hongkongs rückkehr
und vereidigt die neuen regierungschef
john lee der ehemalige sicherheitschef
ist der kommunistischen führung in
peking besonders treu
auch hier kennt die macht der bilder
diese hier sollen sich in der welt
verbreiten um die hoheit darüber zu
haben wurden mehrere medien von den
offiziellen feierlichkeiten
ausgeschlossen der vorwand corona die
bilder sind hieß antwort auf die
freiheitsbewegung
nachdem ihr den sturm überstanden haben
spüren wir schmerzlich dass hongkong es
sich nicht leisten kann chaotisch zu
sein ein land zwei systeme das war das
versprechen 50 jahre lang sollte
hongkong sich selbst verwalten dürfen
mit demokratischen rechten die auf dem
festland nicht gelten offiziell hält
daran fest in der realität ist schon
nach der hälfte der zeit damit schluss
heute leere wo damals bis zu zwei
millionen demonstrierten viele von ihnen
sind inzwischen im gefängnis oder haben
das land verlassen
kein einknicken vor dem druck der straße
das war schon 2009 10 die botschaft von
regina app für die peking treue
politikerin steht fest
china hatte damals keine erfahrungen mit
demokratie und es hatte auch nicht vor
in hongkong wieder eine echte demokratie
einzuführen
das case yvonne offen sprechen kann
liegt daran dass er inzwischen nach
taiwan geflohen ist denn seitdem 2020
erlassenen sicherheitsgesetz kann in
hongkong es folgen haben was im
weitesten sinne gegen china ist casey
bon befürchtet dass es ihm in taiwan
ähnlich ergehen könnte
wenn die zivilisation von hongkong in so
kurzer zeit untergehen kann dann ist das
eine große große warnung an taiwan und
auch an den rest der freien welt
seine feier zum 25 jahrestag ist er eine
beerdigung die beerdigung von hongkongs
hoffnung auf freiheit
die wirtschaftlichen sorgen sind aktuell
groß das spiegelt sich auch im deutschen
leitindex
im juni hat der dax so hohe verluste
verzeichnet wie noch nie zuvor in diesem
monat und die bilanz für das gesamte
erste halbjahr 2020 valerie haller die
sieht ebenfalls alles andere als rosig
aus ja weil das aktuell vermutlich
größte problem die gaskrise sich so
schnell einfach nicht lösen lässt viele
befürchten dass sie eine rezession nach
sich ziehen könnte sollte es zum
lieferstopp kommen müssten
möglicherweise teile der deutschen
wirtschaft für eine weile
heruntergefahren werden ja und außerdem
ist es nur eine frage der zeit bis die
zahlreichen belastungen auch in den
büchern der unternehmen ankommen und
sich daneben auch in gewinnwarnungen
äußern schwierige gemengelagen das erste
börsen halbjahr ist rom es ist das
schwächste seit 14 jahren verlust fast
20 prozent heute hat sich der dax etwas
stabilisiert mehr aber auch nicht heute
wurde außerdem die inflationsrate für
die eurozone veröffentlicht wieder ein
rekordwert warum fällt sie so viel
schlechter aus als die für deutschlands
das liegt daran dass es zum teil ganz
große unterschiede gibt in einigen
ländern werden die hohen gaspreise zum
beispiel schon ziemlich ungefiltert an
die kunden weiter gegeben dass es bei
uns ja noch nicht der fall außerdem
haben tank rabatt und das neun euro
ticket geholfen solche entlastungspaket
die gab es in anderen ländern auch aber
eben nicht alle im juni sondern teils
schon viel früher wirken daher nicht
mehr auf die aktuelle inflationsrate die
im juni einen neuen rekord geknackt hat
um 8,6 prozent zogen die preise in der
eurozone im jahresvergleich an und haben
damit ihren gipfel vermutlich noch nicht
erreicht ebenso wenig in deutschland
laut einer umfrage des ifo instituts
wollen fast alle händler in den
kommenden monaten die lebensmittelpreise
anheben keine guten vorzeichen also
danke valerie für diese einordnung
die 500 jahre alten benin bronson stehen
symbolhaft für eine debatte zum umgang
mit kolonialer raubkunst nun haben
deutschland und nigeria in berlin eine
politische absichtserklärung zur
rückgabe der branche unterzeichnet
außenministerin baerbock sagte dies sei
keine geste sondern ein stück
gerechtigkeit
die ersten beiden bronson wurden dem
vertreter nigerias überreicht weitere
sollen im laufe des jahres folgen vor
125 jahren kamen die bienen bronson als
koloniales raubgut nach deutschlands
und eine nachricht in eigener sache die
rheinland pfälzische ministerpräsident
in malu dreyer wurde heute als
vorsitzende des zdf verwaltungsrats
wiedergewählt
drei er betonte die bedeutung des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks in
zeiten von fake news und propaganda und
sagte das zdf sei jeden tag aufs neue
gefordert mit gut recherchierten
nachrichten für unabhängigen und
glaubwürdigen journalismus einzustehen
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
empfehlen jetzt das brandneue zdf
politbarometer mit matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer die eu handlungsunfähig
der g7 gipfel ein überflüssiges
spektakel die nato hirntod so hieß es
mal wie schnell die zeiten sich ändern
seit dem russischen überfall auf die
ukraine rauft man sich in brüssel
zusammen im bayrischen elmar
demonstrieren die großen 7 den
schulterschluss und in madrid setzt das
transatlantische verteidigungsbündnis
stopp zeichen gegen die aggression des
kreml die früher oft heftigen proteste
gegen den gipfel der mächtigen jetzt
überschaubar und friedlich
eine deutliche mehrheit der befragten 85
prozent findet solche treffen von
staats- und regierungschefs wichtig nur
14 prozent sehen das nicht so
dass die nato für die sicherheit
deutschlands wichtig oder sogar sehr
wichtig ist sagen 90 prozent auch die
militärische hilfe westlicher staaten an
die ukraine hat großen rückhalt
44 prozent sprechen sich dafür aus dass
die unterstützung noch stärker sein
sollte 32 prozent finden dass die
derzeitige hilfe so bleiben sollte 18
prozent fänden es besser wenn der westen
die ukraine militärische weniger
unterstützen würde
dieser krieg wird länger dauern
jedenfalls nicht mehr in diesem jahr
enden davon gehen gut dreiviertel der
befragten aus die mehrheit der deutschen
fühlt sich von der bundesregierung gut
durch diese unsicheren zeiten navigiert
etwa zwei drittel sind mit der arbeit
der ampel zufrieden und diesen zuspruch
profitieren die regierungsparteien
allerdings nicht wenn an diesem sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre würde die spd einen
punkt verlieren 21 prozent cdu/csu 27
plus 1 die grünen 25 fdp 6 afd 10 die
linke 5 prozent alle unverändert
so gerne schwarz grün und auch schwarz
rot auf eine mehrheit schauen wir auf
unsere top ten also die bewertungen der
zehn wichtigsten politikerinnen und
politiker nach sympathie und leistung
auf der skala von +5 bis -5 ist sahra
wagenknecht schlusslicht minus 0,7
vorletzter friedrich merz minus 0,1
etwas schlechter markus söder 0,2
verbessert christian lindner 0,4
deutlich besser davor karl lauterbach
0,7 auf der 15 austria 1,1 hubertus heil
wieder dabei 1,1 auf dem dritten platz
olaf scholz 1,2 leicht verbessert
zweiter annalena baerbock 1,6 und ganz
von robert habeck 2,0 etwas
verschlechtert
auch wenn die statistiker im juni eine
leichte entspannung bei der inflation
gemessen haben die in vielen bereichen
stark gestiegenen preise machen das
leben teurer die deutschen sind
zunehmend besorgt
die stark steigenden preise sind ein
großes problem für den wohlstand in
deutschland sagen 83 prozent deutlich
mehr als noch im april
für 40 prozent sind die stark
gestiegenen preise persönlich ein großes
problem auch das sind mehr als im april
für 60 prozent ist das nicht der fall
für die entlastung der bürger tut die
bundesregierung zu wenig finden die
meisten besonders teuer energie weil wir
nach wie vor abhängig sind von
russischem öl und gas unklar ob in den
gasspeichern bis zum herbst so viel
ankommt dass alle im land wie gewohnt
versorgt werden können der
wirtschaftsminister hat deshalb die
alarmstufe im gas notfallplan ausgerufen
damit jetzt schon gespart wird
mit blick auf den winter gehen 58
prozent davon aus dass es bei der
versorgung mit erdgas zu ernsthaften
problemen für privathaushalte kommen
wird 39 prozent erwarten das nicht mit
einem engpass für die industrie rechnen
sogar drei viertel der befragten
sollte die dritte stufe des gas
notfallplans ausgerufen werden würde
wohl zuerst für unternehmen rationiert
wie das land also am laufen halten ohne
russisches gas und öl
57 prozent sind dafür dass die drei
verbliebenen atomkraftwerke in
deutschland länger betrieben werden als
geplant auch die längere nutzung von
kohlekraftwerken findet eine mehrheit
richtig und fast alle rollen dass der
ausbau erneuerbarer energien jetzt
beschleunigt wird der krieg in der
ukraine inflation und eine drohende
energieknappheit
die herausforderungen sind immens und
werden uns wahrscheinlich noch einiges
abverlangen hoffen wir auf bessere
zeiten
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute ab und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer df punkt
de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
15 juli hier folgt jetzt das wetter
danach geht es weiter mit der sendung
comedy for future mit olaf schubert und
gästen einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die unwetter
kaltfront zieht nun allmählich ab und
nimmt den letzten regen mit dahinter
etabliert sich ein hoch und wir bekommen
wieder warme luft aus dem süden ab noch
wärmer als heiß ist es in italien an
diesem wochenende
dort herrscht eine extreme dürre und die
setzt sich weiter fort
flächendeckender regen ist nicht zu
erwarten wir schauen in die kommende
nacht gibt es regen im nordosten das
verabschiedet sich langsam es klart
häufig auf und in gewässernähe zum
beispiel richtung donau da bildet sich
nebel die tiefsten temperaturen liegen
bei 6 grad in der mitte deutschlands und
14 grad richtung nordsee dort ist es am
mildesten morgen im tagesverlauf geht
häufig sonnenschein nach osten hin und
auch im süden nach norden sind einige
harmlose wolken unterwegs aber es gibt
keinen regen und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von 30 grad im südwesten
deutschlands häufig wird die 25 grad
marke überschritten am kürzen ist es
noch mit 22 grad richtung nordsee und
schleswig holstein und 23 grad an der
ostsee die kommenden tage am sonntag ist
es trocken und verbreitet sonnig zum
abend hin kommen im nordwesten schauer
auf temperaturen bis 31 grad ab montag
ist es nicht mehr ganz so heißt die 30
grad marke wird nicht mehr überschritten
dafür gibt es im süden gewitter und ganz
im norden schauer damit ein schöner
abend